hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
top k frequent elements i really like
this problem because it's pretty
clever and once you figure it out the
code is really easy to write
so we're given an input array nums and
an
integer k and we want to return the k
most frequent elements that appear in
the array nums
we can return the answer in any order so
for example we have this
input array three ones two twos
and a single three and we wanna return
the two most
frequent elements right so we know that
the most frequent is of course
one it appears three times so we add a
one to the output
the second most frequent is two so then
we add a 2 to the output and that's all
we want now if
if k was 3 of course we'd add the last
element
k is never going to be greater than the
distinct number of elements in the input
array so that's good for us
and our input array is always going to
be non-empty so for example for each
value right we're going to
count how many occurrences it has so for
example one
occurs three times two occurs
twice and three occurs once
and then we can take this basically this
list of pairs right then we can sort it
in ascending order right so
basically it's already sorted in
ascending order right because the most
frequent is here
the second most frequent is here the
third most frequent is here right
now of course sorting it in the worst
case right basically
if every single value in here was
distinct and we wanted the top k
distinct values
we'd get a time complexity of n log
n right but we don't necessarily need to
sort the entire thing because
we only want the top k frequent elements
so in another solution we could actually
use
a max heap so we would still do this
whole operation where we count the
number of occurrences of each value and
then we'd add each pair
to our max heap and the key of this max
heap would
of course be the number of occurrences
right so the count right
and then we'd pop from our heap exactly
k times so why is this more efficient
well we know popping
from the heap well first of all we when
we initialize our heap we're going to
add this entire set and there's a
function called
heapify i think that can do that in
actually
linear time so big o of n time so that's
the good thing and of course we know
we're only going to be popping from the
heap
k times each pop is going to take log n
and we're going to be doing that k times
right so that's going to be
k times log n right so that's a little
bit better than
n log n at least as long as k is
less than n right but it turns out that
there's actually an
even better solution there's actually a
solution that can be done
in o of n time linear time
so big o of n time and big o of n memory
but we are still going to be using this
exact
a technique where for each value like
one we count the number of recurrences
like three so this problem can actually
be solved in linear time if you use the
algorithm called
bucket sore so when you first think of
bucket sort this is probably what you're
going to think of
the way bucket sort is usually taught is
that for each value for example 1
we're going to take an input array right
this is our input array this
this row is the indices the index of the
array and this is actually going to be
the value so for example for one
we're going to go to the posit the index
one and in the value we're gonna put
okay one occurs exactly once now we're
gonna see a second one we're gonna say
one occurs twice right basically we're
going to go through the input array
count how many times
each value occurs and then in our input
array
put that count for that index right map
the value to the index and then put the
count of that value so 1 occurs 3 times
2 occurs twice 100 in this case occurs
once now this algorithm would be
linear time if our input values right
were bounded for example if we knew for
a fact that every value
was between 1 and 10 then we would know
that the size of our input array is also
going to be 10 right but in this case
the values are unbounded right like this
could have been
a million and then the size of our input
array would have been a million even
though the total
input array size is only six right we
have six elements
but then that array where we actually
store the buckets
sort values is going to be unbounded
right and also we want the top k
elements this still isn't very clear of
where exactly the top k
elements are actually going to be so in
this case this type of bucket sort
doesn't work but there's another way
we can do it so in this case you can see
for our
for our array where we're going to be
doing the bucket sort the index
i was using the each value in the
inquiry for example you know one was
being mapped to index one right and
there we were storing the count
there's actually another tricky way that
you can do it that will lead us to a
linear time solution
so if we're pretty clever this is what
we're going to do
for the index we're actually going to be
mapping
the accounts of each value and in the
values we're actually going to have a
list of which values have exactly
this particular count for example
a hundred right we know that a hundred
occurs
one time so what we're gonna do is for
this position
one we're gonna say okay this value
occurs only once a hundred a hundred
occurs one single time which value
for another value in our input array 2
we see it occurs exactly twice right we
can count that with a hash map pretty
easily
and then we'll say okay this value
occurs twice so in the position
2 index position 2 of our array we're
going to add that value 2.
2 is the value that occurs twice we see
a
last distinct value in our input array
1. we count it occurs exactly three
times so in this position
index 3 we're gonna say okay there's a
value a single value a one
that occurs three times now it's
possible maybe we had a third
three right maybe two occurs three times
in that case
we would actually have multiple values
in this position right but in this case
we can see one occurs three times two
occurs twice
100 occurs once so they're all going to
go in separate positions
and then you know once we've taken every
single input value and then
and counted how many times each value
occurs and then put it in the
appropriate spot in this array what are
we going to do well
we want the top k values right the
values that occur
the top k values that occur most
frequently right so what are we going to
do we're going to start at this
end of the array we want all the values
that occur
six times why are we stopping at six
though why don't i extend this array
farther right seven
eight a hundred right why did the
indices stop at six
notice something about our input array
our input array is
size six right so that means if every
single
value in the input array was the exact
same the
most number of times a value could occur
would be exactly
six time so the cool thing about this in
about this new array that we're creating
is it's bounded
by six or well technically six plus one
because we do have a zero but that's not
actually necessary
but it's basically it's proportionate to
the size of the input array right so
so you know when we're scanning from
right to left or
however we do it we're only going to be
doing that we can scan through the
entire thing in linear time
now in this case we see six there's no
values that occur six times so we can't
find our top k element
in that position we'll try the same
thing with five
five no values occur five times four
no values occur four times three oh a
single value we're going to go through
every
value in this array there's only a
single value in this case
but we do see a 1 occur so to our result
we want the top k values
the top k occurring values we are going
to add a 1 to that
1 occurs most frequently in the input
array so
we add one to our result we need one
more because i think we were looking for
the top
two values k in this case is going to be
two so now we're going to go here which
values occur
twice a single value and that value is
two
so we're going to add that to our output
array so now we've gotten the top two
values
and then we can return this array now
why is this linear time again
because remember the max size that this
array could possibly be is going to be
about equal to the size of the input
array right because we could have a
value for example one could occur six
times in that case we'd have
one over here now what if every single
value in the input array was distinct
right that's another extreme what if we
had one
two three four five six
in that case this position would be
empty because no values occur six times
no values occur
five times four times three times or two
times
every one of these six values would go
in
this position at index one reason being
each one of these occurs exactly once so
in that case we'll have
all six values concentrated over here
and that's still going to be linear time
because yes we are going to be iterating
through this entire input array which is
going to be big o
of n and then we're going to add another
big o of n
to that right big o of n plus big o of n
because we're going to have to iterate
through six values in exactly one
position
so that's still technically linear time
now we are creating this
uh array to help us and we're also going
to be needing a hash map to
count the occurrences of each value in
the input array so the memory complexity
is also going to be big o
of n with that being said let's jump
into the linear time code it's pretty
easy once you can identify this
trick so we are going to use a hash map
to count the occurrences of each value
or also
the array the special array that's going
to be the same size as the input array
about
is going to be called frequency
basically you know
the index is going to be the frequency
of an element or the count of an element
and the value is just going to be the
list of
values that occur that particular many
number of times
so i'm going to have an empty i'm going
to initialize this as an empty array
the number of empty arrays that go in
this is going to be about
the size of our input plus one
so now i'm just going to go through
every value in nums and just count how
many times it occurs so for count of
this particular end value we're going to
do
1 plus what its current count is count
dot
get n now if n doesn't already exist in
our hash map or dictionary
we're just going to put a default value
of zero so this will return zero if it
doesn't exist but this is
how we're going to be counting the
number of times each value in nums
occurs
next we're going to be going through
each value that we counted so
n c in count
dot items because that's going to return
the key value pair every single key
value pair that we added to
our dictionary and for every key value
pair for every number
and count i want to change the free i
want to in the frequency array i want to
insert so for this particular
count remember the count is what's going
to be the index so
at index count we're going to append to
that list
this value n what we're saying is this
value
n occurs exactly c number of times
and once we've done this we've basically
initialized everything we need to so now
we're going to have our
result output right we want the top k
elements so
4 and so we're going to be iterating
through this array frequency in
descending order right because we want
to start with the numbers that occur
most frequently so for i
in range length of frequency
minus one which is the last index and
we're going to go all the way
up until zero and we're going to be
going in descending order so we're going
to put a negative 1 as the decrementer
and we're going to go through every
value so for every let's say
n value in frequency at this index
i because we know everything inserted in
i is actually another sub list so it
could be empty or it could have some
values whatever it does so let's say
n is non-empty then we're going to go
ahead and take that
end value and append it to our result
because we're basically getting the end
value that occurs
most frequently now when are we going to
stop at some point our result
output is going to be the exact same
size as k
because we're guaranteed to have at
least k values in our input array so
once that happens
once if the length of result is matching
exactly k
that's when we can go ahead and return
result we know this is
guaranteed to execute at some point so
we don't have to put a return statement
outside of the loop
and that is the entire code so we could
have solved this problem
in decent time if we used a heap it
wouldn't be too bad k
log n i think that's a doable solution
but with this kind of neat trick
we can do this in big o of n time and i
hope that you did learn something maybe
a little about
a little bit about bucket sort this
problem definitely taught me something
when i first solved it
and i know many people have been
requesting problems and i'm trying to
get
to all those requested problems as
quickly as i can so i hope it was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching